[Musique]
l'économie américaine tourne au ralenti
pour un deuxième trimestre consécutif
avec un recul de 0,9% du PIB mais la
politique monétaire agressive avec une
nouvelle augmentation des taux d'intérêt
hier devrait suffire à éviter la
récession selon Joe Biden dans une
chambre
éventuellement des réactions également
chez nous au Canada et Québec avec une
croissance économique qui devrait
ramasser de façon quand même assez
importante éventuellement
l'économie canadienne s'en sort mieux
sur les fronts de l'emploi et du secteur
immobilier mais le scénario d'une
stackflation croissance mince combinée à
une hausse du coût de la vie fera des
consommateurs les principales victimes
c'est sûr qu'on le remarque sur le
portefeuille mais on essaie de trouver
les économies qu'il y en a les prix
augmentent depuis des années ça diminue
pas je sais pas à quel point le
gouvernement va faire en sorte de
des délais citoyens les ménages sont un
peu perdants des deux côtés là donc on
paye plus cher mais en plus on est un
peu pénalisé par le relâchement de
l'économie le débat reste entier à
savoir si les États-Unis entrent en
récession ou non avec ses conséquences
sur l'économie canadienne et si
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal